saffron I understand that you and your
family your sisters they all rallied
around your grandparents when they were
trying to navigate the internet for the
first few times what year was that and
what was it like watching them I think
it was 2009 or my grandparents learned
to use the internet they're both about
80 years old and their main reason for
wanting to get online was we have
relatives that live in Ireland we have a
younger cousin he's about five years old
and they were upset that they weren't
there seeing him grow up so they decided
to get online so that they could skype
with him every day so they started you
know skyping with him while he ate his
dinner at night my uncle would bring his
iphone to soccer games to piano lessons
so they could watch him as he was
growing up via Skype and it was just
incredible for them to be able to do
that what were some of their fears at
first and what were some of the things
that delighted them aside from being
able to see someone face to face almost
through a computer screen I think with
most seniors and it's scary getting
online especially if you've never used a
computer before a lot of them are afraid
that they're going to press a button
that breaks the entire computer and then
you know it's done or they get stuck
something freezes or something's not
working and they they're too afraid to
figure out how to fix it so it just sits
there for weeks and weeks so those are
some of the obstacles but you have the
ability to connect with family even with
family that doesn't live that far away I
mean we live an hour away from our
grandparents but having them on Facebook
and Skype they were just able to look
more deeply into our lives and it made
us a lot closer with them so then from
that experience I believe yours two
sisters began their own sort of
organization to help other seniors can
you talk about that yeah they wanted to
help other seniors get online so my two
sisters started going to local
retirement residence and giving the
seniors lessons and they started just
asking their school friends people in
their classes if they want to tag along
and I think there was a group of about
15 of them that would go to the
retirement residence two days a week
after school and give
our long lessons to the seniors what was
in it for you know I'm dating myself
calling them the young people but the
younger generation the Millennials or
the Generation Y people that what did
they feel compelled to to give back to
these seniors what was the reason I
think the main driving reason for a lot
of the students who join in this program
in the beginning is taking on a
leadership role in their communities
which looks really great on college
applications and job applications so my
sisters also did it for community
service hours they needed to get 100
community service hours in order to
graduate high school so they were
looking for interesting ways to help out
in their community but i think you know
once the students get into it they end
up teaching for longer than they need to
to fulfill those 100 hours community
service because they just enjoy it i
mean it's fun and i think they start to
realize they really like helping out in
their community and this is something
that comes naturally to them so it's not
a difficult thing for them to do to give
these computer lessons yeah cyber
seniors shows such great moments between
the two generations on the computer and
you did see this relationship develop
amongst all of them and it was it was
really sweet to see you know how quote
faster the younger generation was and
then the older generation was oh how did
you do that you make this go so fast
please you know and it was great to see
the relationship between the two of them
how did the seniors sign up like what
was their reasoning they hear about the
internet sounds like they were scared of
it a little bit but they were still
intrigued what was their reasoning did
they tell you yeah I think for a lot of
them they hear so much about the
internet they say you know my kids live
in front of their computers my grandkids
live in front of their computers and I
don't know anything about it I want to
know a little bit more about what's
going on definitely the driving factor
for them was getting in touch with
family they wanted to they see their
grandkids on facebook all the time so
they want to be on facebook too they
want to be able to skype with them and
communicate with them how did you get
access to these seniors now you're going
to these retirement homes what's your
pitch to them to let you come in not
just
you know as the program but then
eventually with the cameras it was
pretty hard getting access to these
retirement residences actually because
they're usually parts a part of big
chains of retirement residences so to
get to the top person it's kind of hard
we ended up getting access to two
different retirement residences that let
us film there which was great because
when we were in a retirement residence
we were able to you know give lessons to
40 seniors at a time and kind of go
door-to-door with our film crew and be
able to film them and I guess the
retirement residences allowed us to do
that because they love the idea of the
program the seniors in their retirement
residences we're asking for computer
lessons and then for us to be able to
bring in all these young people to give
the lessons I mean they loved it yeah i
love the opening shot of the film to
where you have like a walker going
through the corridors and i just think
that's so great because it it just
really sets the tone for the film so
once you met with the seniors how did
you tell them about being on camera and
how how scared were they or or actually
it encouraged to be you know not only
that they're using the internet but now
they're having this weird machine look
at them with sound equipment and lights
how intimidating was that for them yeah
a lot of them were intimidated by the
camera but they really quickly forgot
about it I think it's really interesting
when you watch reality TV shows you
always wonder how can people act like
that on camera but all the seniors
agreed it's kind of like you put on a
microphone and the cameras there but
then you forget about it because you're
just having a conversation with somebody
right and some of them actually liked me
on camera like sure our main stars I
think part of the reason why she got
involved because she wanted to be in a
movie she thought that that was really
cool oh yes she's definitely
well-positioned enfranchised I really
enjoyed watching her so where does the
cyber seniors program stand now or your
sister still involved and how many
volunteers do you have my sisters are in
college right now so when they're home
for summer holidays they do go back and
teach seniors lessons so they are still
involved
but for now what we're trying to do with
the cyber seniors program has encouraged
other students to bring this program to
their own communities so we have
resources on our website downloadable
handbooks that you can use as like a
teaching guide and yeah we're just
trying to encourage other people to do
exactly what my sister is data it's not
that difficult to kind of call around
your community figure out who wants
these types of programs retirement
residences libraries who have senior
citizens looking for these types of
lessons and you can just rally up your
friends and go in and teach them so how
many volunteers did you have in the
beginning you said what was it 20 or 15
and then we had about 20 students in the
beginning of our film and we had about
30 senior citizens and now where does
the program stand in terms of volunteers
in the retirement residences that we are
working and I think there's about five
students in the retirement residences
okay and then so so this cyber seniors
program is this then started through
sort of your website and then people
then download all of the packages to
take into their area is that how it is
yeah so we're providing resources but
other websites provide resources as well
for example AARP has a program called
mentor up so we're partnering with them
they're sponsoring a few screenings of
our film to promote their own program
and its exact same idea its young people
mentoring older people to learn
technology and then what was the time
frame for the actual filming of cyber
seniors how long did it take we shot
over a period of 10 months and the
editing took about a year so it was a
two-year project altogether and you
edited the film yes okay so what did you
learn about this older generation versus
the newer generation I mean like what
what parallels did you see I'm sure
probably the need to connect but then
also what were some of the things that
were a complete opposite that you saw I
think it just really opened my eyes the
ID
you know life isn't over once you
reached that age these people are still
totally active totally with it and
they're having a lot of fun retirement
age actually seems like fun to me now
because they have a free time to kind of
do things that they've always wanted to
do so it's a really good time in your
life to be able to you know take on your
skills like learning how to use the
computer and I think people that do
continue learning and taking on new
skills are the ones that really thrive
later in life I'm wondering what it is
that makes us resist technology as we
get older because I'm right now all of
us oh the internet seems fine we're used
we've kind of grown up around it but I'm
sure there'll be things in 20 years that
will seem entirely scary whether it's a
matrix-like device or you know plug in
and you get certain feelings and oh my
gosh you know we can't do this but what
do you think it is in us that makes us
resist technology as we get older well
with the seniors featured in our film
they're in their 80s and 90s so they
were out of the workforce once computers
became mainstream so they never really
had to learn how to use the internet as
a necessity for school or work so it's
completely new to them and I think that
that's really scary I think when you
have a basis for computer knowledge
you're able to pick up new technology
easier but still I mean people that are
five years younger than me are so much
faster on the internet than I am and
they know things are apps or different
technological things that I can't grasp
myself and I think you can get kind of
lazy it's kind of like no this is my
routine I'm not gonna learn anything new
but I think it's good to challenge
yourself and keep learning new things
and keep up to date on new technology
because it is easy to fall behind what
are some of the things that seem new to
you with the internet like different
apps or you know what like what um well
every time I new app comes out like
there was snapchat now I'm really into
snapchat but my sisters are on snapchat
for like a year it was before I even
knew about it once I got on snapchat was
like
yeah that's old news we've been using
that for a year my mom is just now
getting on Instagram and snapchat so you
know it's like she takes to it a little
bit slower and then once my mom's on
Instagram it's like okay now I need to
tone down some of the photos that I'm
hosting on the older generation kind of
comes in that's funny because that was
one of the the scenes between one of the
volunteers and one of the women that
lived in the community I think she was
in her late 70s I think yeah g-unit oh
and that I'm sorry I'm sorry and so she
was looking at her grandchildren's
photos and was like oh little surprise
that yeah the volunteers like that's why
I just have photos of me running through
the meadow yeah more people and um one
thing you mentioned in the film is that
the older generation seems to be more
reserved and doesn't want to be as
boastful we're of course now it's all
about promoting yourself in this new you
know online world so how was that seeing
the two worlds you know contrasted the
more polite not wanting to be too
forward whereas you know now anything
basically goes yeah well again the
younger people grew up with the internet
so they're kind of used to this idea of
posting their status updates posting
their photos blasting themselves all
over the internet because everybody's
doing that so it's the norm or as for
older people they're not used to it so
it seems very forward to be posting
photos of yourself and adding people on
Facebook who you don't even know that
well in real life I know with a net she
also had a really excellent point which
I thought was incredibly astute of her
to notice because she wasn't very versed
in facebook but she said oh adding or
dropping a friend this is where these
machines quote her her terminology get
very dangerous because people feel
insulted and the volunteer that helped
he said oh that's not that big a deal
because she said oh no no no this is
where it and I I wonder do you think
that connections these days maybe aren't
as serious as maybe that generation
where you really locked in this is your
friend and you keep them for a long time
worth
now or more transient you know we're
just sort of in and out oh let's add
this person or yeah drop them well
definitely I think that because the main
reason for the seniors getting online
was to connect with family they weren't
that interested in connecting with
acquaintances they weren't very
interested in meeting new friends online
which a lot of young people are totally
comfortable doing it was just it wasn't
something that interested them it was
like oh why don't you chat with this
person why would try online dating and
some of them went for it but it never
really clicked for them it was that's
fine that was funny and fun but my main
reason is one hundred percent to speak
with my family but the one thing I found
interesting too is that I think younger
people contribute the most to web
content right they're the ones posting
YouTube videos and blogging and the
senior citizens aren't doing that so in
our film when we did the YouTube
competition the seniors pairing up with
young people to create YouTube videos it
was a really great way for the seniors
to have a voice online which I don't
think they do I mean everything you see
is posted by primarily younger people
right so we really wanted to encourage
them to you know post videos of what can
you teach me what can you teach the
younger generation right yeah i mean
sure as video was just so much fun and
i'll save that for people to watch the
film how competitive did they get with
each other or how invested they become
in these likes and comments and the
views because people you know even in
their 40s that post videos it becomes
this huge thing you know you want to
read what people have written you want
to see how many views does it have how
did they react to that some seniors got
very competitive during the youtube
competition and you'll see that in the
film and it was funny to see I mean
Shora you know gets kind of caddy about
the other videos and just constantly
updating your status looking for more
views she was loving the attention
because it was her kids and grandkids
who were then posted on their Facebook
going this is my grandma check it out
she's loving it and some people thought
you know that wasn't a good thing to put
in the documentary because it shows kind
of the dark side of the internet that
you know it can make you slightly
narcissistic because you're just craving
all its attention
but um I just thought it'd show that you
know she's just like anybody else she
was just like the teenagers who wanted
the hits on the videos I just thought it
was kind of funny the tables had turned
yeah I think that's interesting because
I saw that too and I loved how she was
always so well put together Riviera is
she's had these incredible outfits on
and and it did show that maybe it's just
part of human nature that we want that
praise and that attention and whether
you're 89 or you know 15 you know you
still want that I thought that was a
great thing and then with the
competition what ended up happening for
the people that didn't win how did they
take it were they able to kind of dust
it off or yeah there was slight
disappointment there was one video that
was really popular but it didn't win one
of the top three prizes it was Ehlert's
video and yeah he was a little bit upset
which I didn't expect cuz he didn't care
that much about the competition while I
was going on then we were announcing
winners and you see his face draw a
little bit sad but he knew he had a
great video it still has you know some
of the most hits of all the videos that
we have posted online so how did you
choose the seniors to be in the dock
because you just have just the most
lovable like oh I want to take them home
and have them be my grandparents you
know like how did you choose them i'm
sure there's probably some that you
couldn't use for whatever reason maybe
they were still great but it just didn't
fit into the realm of the story so what
was the selection process like well we
started off filming was a huge group of
senior citizens and we kind of just went
door-to-door in the retirement residents
giving them lessons and filming and you
slowly we just started narrowing down
based on the people that were most into
it the ones that were picking it up
quickly and the ones that were
interesting to watch on camera the
people that you know liked being on
camera
we're kind of warm towards this one the
cameras there some people just didn't
like being from the camera so that
helped doesn't narrow them out you're
just lucky to find some really funny
charismatic senior citizens and there
were some that didn't make the final cut
who you know we're in an edit even a
year ago that I just had to cut a few
months ago just because there wasn't
enough time but yeah we were just really
lucky with the people that we found yeah
it's an excellent mix and I'll always
excuse me I like to how they were very
open about some of their family
situations and not holding back
especially to being from a generation
that's probably not as open about things
I thought that they shared some
interesting things yeah I found
especially with the men I mean to see
men of that age kind of open up and be
even a little bit emotional on camera is
not something that you're used to seeing
but you know we had these 90 year old
men who would talked about their family
with such pride and got a little
teary-eyed when they got you know
Facebook message things like that I
thought were really heartwarming saffron
I understand with the film and I don't
want to give too many spoilers away this
might for some people watching so viewer
beware but you had your own family
situations within the film how soon did
these situations happen when you began
the documentary and your choice to weave
them in the story well about halfway
through filming the documentary my
sister was diagnosed with cancer when we
started filming my grandfather had
cancer and i was gonna focus on that
story line because my sisters were the
ones that started the program because
they were inspired by my grandparents so
i wanted to keep that story in and how
you know the internet has helped my
family stay in touch and stay close so
when my sister was diagnosed pathetic
what do we do now do we keep filming and
there was a period where we kind of
thought you know we're not gonna film
that we're not going to put that
film but um it's strange what happens
when you don't know how you're gonna
deal with the crisis like that it kind
of becomes your new normal it was like I
wasn't filming when we were all crying
or when something really devastating was
happening but I was at the hospital with
her every day we'd all take turns going
to the hospital and she'd pick up her
phone and skype my grandparents you know
because they wanted to see her and see
how she was doing and that was our life
at the time so I would just I filmed a
bit of it and it ended up in the film
and I'm really happy that I have that
footage because it was really
interesting the way the internet helped
my sister and my grandfather stayed
close they're both going through cancer
treatment at the same time the internet
allowed them to kind of check up on one
another it was this weird bond that they
shared but it was a really kind of sweet
relationship that develops yeah the film
definitely shows that and and your
sister is doing well today yeah calling
very well she's in complete remission
she's off at NYU studying huh Wow yeah
well congratulations yeah well my hats
off to you to show that in the film
because I'm sure probably it was
difficult but maybe in some ways you
looked at it almost from a new
perspective because it was like you're
filming and sometimes you're removed you
know you're more of the just this viewer
but yeah did you have to really discuss
amongst your family should we include
this or was it just like this is part of
our lives and we're going to show it
there was no hesitation yeah there was
discussion about it and there's actually
not a ton of footage of that it's it's
woven throughout that story but it's not
a huge part of the story because i
didn't spend hours and hours of filming
it there was just a few moments where i
was kind of like this is a really cute
moment i might as well grab it and put
it on camera and I'm glad I did and some
of those scenes still make us choked up
and cry even I've seen the film like 200
times no nose and I see some of the
film's a tweet like the scenes between
my sister my grandfather it still gets
me choked up but again i'm glad that i
have that and i think my entire family
really actually enjoys seeing it